but first i know many of us will be
getting out of the house this summer and
enjoying the great outdoors
and with lake mead in our backyard you
don't have to go far let me show you how
[Music]
last season on the lake we went
wakeboarding we went jet skiing we
explored
secret coves and today we're going
fishing
hey bruce hey jc how you doing i got
your rod for you a child's rod this is
perfect
what kind of uh what kind of boat we're
going out so last time we took out that
400 halite yes today we're gonna upgrade
a little bit we're gonna take with a
1985 boston whaler
what that that's absolutely perfect this
is gonna be an amazing day
so when this boat came off the factory
line ronald reagan was the president as
he was but there's a cool backstory on
it though huh yeah so we're we're
actually a boston whaler dealer this is
a 1985 boston whaler originally was sold
as a fishing boat to a fishing guide
and it's not a work boat for us but we
were the very first boston wheeler
dealer my grandparents were
in 1958 or 59 on the west coast
[Music]
we made it las vegas bay now now bruce
this is i was inside your bait shop and
this one this this lower
color floor caught my eye if it caught
your eye it's going to catch fish's eyes
exactly so can we put that one on on
this this rod here let's do it let me
grab it and grab your finger perfect
i read something that fish they actually
can they can smell stuff yeah it's the
fact that our
our hands and our scent is now all over
that lore that might um
we rubbed our hands and anchovies to
start so that's the trick
and there's the switch right yeah so
flip the switch
here bring it back to you and then if
you hold your finger just like you got
it yeah
and then open it up oh that's the gopro
in the water
i'll go in and get it this is the life
fishing the lake
when it comes to speed does it matter i
think you come in real slow and just
lure that fish in
no pun intended i think the fish are
laughing i said we dropped the gopro in
the water
probably i was looking online doing some
research okay and it said when it comes
to fishing
las vegas bay which is where we are
prime time is like four or five
six o'clock in the morning yeah yeah
yeah we're like uh four or five o'clock
at night yeah based
on the sun this is this is high noon
right now yeah not looking good yeah
don't lose bearing on our gopro now does
the engine scare the fish
absolutely if you're watching right now
the trick is to take note as to what
bruce and i are doing and do the
complete opposite
opposite you roll up i'm screaming i
don't know why
scaring all the fish oh yeah it's on now
this this is a classic
shakespeare fishing rod this is actually
i had a shakespeare's again yeah yeah
this is the spider-man version here we
go this one's very simple push the
button
hold the button look at that
throat and there you go that's it look
at that right there look
bruce caught something yeah we're eating
a stick for dinner tonight
it's operation rescue gopro time
do you have a net or anything no
we're not real fishermen
[Music]
let's recap photographer lance broke his
headphones we lost a gopro
in the lake and bruce we didn't catch
any fish but i tell you what it still
was an amazing afternoon yeah we had a
great day but you know what we
appreciate having you down so we got
some fish and chips in the boathouse for
you here let's do it all right
great awesome is this uh work as a shirt
absolutely you're perfect come on in
if you want to try your luck at fishing
or any other lake activities go to
boatinglakemed.com